the American investor Warren Buffett
says his berkshire hathaway group has
sold all of its shares in the four
largest US airlines he said travel was
likely to be much reduced in the next
three to four years because of the
corona virus pandemic well Anthony
Pompey I know is the author of the pump
letter which looks at investing and he
watched Warren Buffett's talk earlier
and he good to see you thanks for being
with us so this not good line not good
news for the airlines there at all yeah
look in 2016 when Buffett took the
airline position I think it surprised
people he'd spent years kind of avoiding
the airline investments and then he
owned about 10% in the four largest US
airlines and so getting rid of the
decision today he was pretty
intellectually honest and said that he
had made a mistake
obviously the coronaviruses had a
negative impact on u.s. travel in that
entire industry and so they've exited
the position and they look elsewhere to
put the cash as they continue to invest
I mean kindly send certain times and
obviously for people who don't know he's
a huge a Titanic figure in the world of
share buying and investing and what else
as he said today
yeah his main message was basically
these are uncertain times but he along
with many other investors believed that
to never bet against America right his
belief is look I don't know how long
this will last
I actually don't know if the stock
market's gonna go up or down or how long
that may take to get a full recovery but
over long periods of time betting
against the United States is probably a
bad bet and so he's still long America
and will continue to kind of do what
he's done for the last number of decades
it served him well in the past and I
along with many others think that I'll
continue to serve him well moving
forward yeah it certainly I served him
well in the past doesn't it what about
this apparent disconnect more widely
between the state of the US economy and
the stock market yeah you know it's very
obvious that the US stock market is not
a representation of the economy it's a
representation of central bank actions
right so what we've seen over the last
couple of weeks is unemployment GDP
everything's going down all of kind of
the
economic data is going negative but the
stock market is rallying is there's this
dislocation between kind of the economic
carnage on the ground and then what the
stock investors are seeing and so at
some point I think that there has to be
some continuity there right that there
either has to be the stock market coming
down to meet the reality or the reality
has to improve to kind of meet those
expectations of stock investors but
there's definitely a dislocation right
now and that's being driven by the
central bank the Federal Reserve is
printed you know three plus trillion
dollars at this point and it doesn't
look like they're gonna slow down and so
that money printing is definitely kind
of inflating asset prices right now and
you just looking at the economy are more
widely what kind of timeframes are you
putting on the recovery how long was
this gonna take well step one is the
economy is not gonna recover while
anyone's sitting at home right you've
got to get people back to work safely
you've got to get them spending money
again consuming so that's kind of the
first step the second step then is if
anyone's ever run a business before you
can't shut down your business send all
of your employees home tell all of your
customers that you're closed down and
then just start it back up on day one
and immediately have all your employees
back in all the customers back right it
takes time to do that and so I don't
think that we're gonna kind of see this
v-shape recovery that some people are
talking about instead I think that this
is gonna take you know 12 to 18 months
to kind of get people's feet back
underneath them and then also we're
gonna see a lot of businesses not come
back right in the united states 50% of
jobs or from small businesses it
wouldn't surprise me to see 20% of small
businesses in the u.s. not make it
through this economic downturn which is
really sad but but I think that's kind
of the reality that we're facing right
now yeah huge times thank you very much
for talking us through that Antonia
Pompey Ana you got